bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end l
émission consacrée à vos loisirs et vos
idées de sorties alors au programme de
la musique du cinéma et du sport mais
tout d'abord place à notre première
invitée ce dimanche 7 juin de 10 heures
à 18 heures la ferme de grignon organise
sa traditionnelle journée portes
ouvertes pour en parler avec nous en
plateau 110 fouquet bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes le responsable accueil
et communication à la ferme de grignon
beaucoup de choses sont proposées lors
de cette journée par où commencer
alors pour arriver dans la cour de ferme
on va faire les choses dans l'ordre on
aura beaucoup d'animations pour les
enfants pour les grands sur la
biodiversité sur tout ce qui est en lien
avec l'agriculture l'alimentation
l'environnement et le développement
durable quels types d'animations par
exemple alors on va avoir par exemple
une vache à traire pour les enfants pour
qu'ils apprennent un petit peu une
fausse vaches
évidemment on fera pas toute la journée
avec une vraie vache on va avoir des
jeux sur la biodiversité donc apprendre
à découvrir la biodiversité
voilà en répondant à des petites
questions et puis avec des petits lots à
gagner
sur chaque opération des marchés de
producteurs sont également proposés tout
à fait on aura 18 producteurs présents
donc on a des producteurs locaux on a
des lycées agricoles qui seront là
également
tout ça pour pour faire déguster leurs
produits pour proposer leurs produits et
puis et puis pour que les gens puissent
les découvrir des visites également donc
ça c'est sans interruption tout ça des
animations le marché est également des
visites ou les
visiteurs pourront même caressé nourrir
les animaux tout à fait alors quoi qu'il
arrive les visites libres seront
évidemment permise tout au long de la
journée et on organisera aussi des
visites guidées toutes les heures on a
un départ de visites toutes les heures
des visites qui dureront à peu près une
demi heure pour expliquer un petit peu
aux gens ce qu'on fait à la ferme et
puis le projet environnemental sur
lequel on travaille un atelier culinaire
disco soupe également tout à fait donc
c'est via l'association ingénieurs sans
frontières d'agroparistech notamment qui
viendra qui viendra proposer au public
de fabriquer des soupes des salades des
compotes et puis chacun repartira avec
avec son petit ces petites gourmandises
fabriquer très bien également des
animations aux causes horaire bien
précises l'une d'elles donc c'est de 10h
à 13h et de 14h à 18h notamment des
démonstrations de chiens de troupeaux
tout à fait on a un berger qui vient sur
l'exploitation avec ses deux chiens et
qui viendra donc il fera une
démonstration et puis ensuite qui
commentera ce qui l'a fait pourquoi il
l'a fait et puis comment il a dressé ses
animaux etc
des baptêmes de poneys également
baptêmes de poneys on a le centre
équestre des le poney club ddr qui vient
et qui proposera des baptêmes poneys
tout au long de la journée avec une
petite pause entre entre 13h et 14h pour
que les poneys puisse se reposer un peu
notre activité qui risque de plaire
beaucoup on pourra apparemment donné le
biberon aux agneaux oui tout à fait
alors ça ça provoque toujours de gros
mouvements doul dans la bergerie donc à
10 heures le matin et vers 16 heures
l'après-midi les enfants puisque on
privilégie les enfants à ce moment là
pourront entrer directement dans les
parcs avec le berger pour proposer les
biberons aux petits agneaux tient
finalement l'objectif de ces portes
ouvertes alors l'objectif c'est de faire
découvrir la ferme est aussi de faire
découvrir le monde agricole
et puis d'expliquer aux gens que la
plupart des agriculteurs français
aujourd'hui travail en agriculture
raisonnée et donc voir un petit peu
quelles sont nos actions envers
l'environnement et à l'année à la femme
du gagnant vous proposer des activités
régulières
quels types d'activités proposées tout
au long de l'année pour ceux qui ça peut
intéresser peut-être à leur visite libre
et gratuite tout au long de l'année
c'est ouvert tous les jours les gens
peuvent se balader dans la ferme
participer au biberon également quand
quand on est en période de naissance
assister à la traite des vaches visiter
la laiterie depuis l'extérieur puisque
évidemment pour des raisons d'hygiène on
ne peut pas entrer à l'intérieur et puis
la boutique gourmande qui est ouverte
aussi elle lui mercredi au dimanche
on n'a pas précisé les portes ouvertes
c'est gratuit accessible et rentrer
gratuite bien sûr bien sûr très bien bon
bah merci beaucoup pour tout ces
informations je rappelle en tout cas la
journée portes ouvertes c'est ce
dimanche de 10h à 18h de quoi passer une
belle journée en famille le soleil
devrait être au rendez vous tout est
fait il est recommandé
on croise les doigts exactement merci
beaucoup quant à nous on conditions
continuent cette édition avec les rendez
vous musicaux du week end
la chorale de si de là sera en concert
ce samedi 6 juin en l'église saint
martin des clayes-sous-bois le choeur
sera accompagné d'une quintette à cordes
pour un concert classique autour du
credo de vivaldi et lui une messe de
mozart
nous avons suivi la dernière répétition
dernière répétition pour le coeur de ci
de là
école marcel pagnol aux clayes-sous-bois
c'est dans cette salle de place que l'on
retrouve la chef de choeur sandrine
compte six coeurs et ses cinquante
choristes pour un concert à une semaine
de la représentation s'est entourée du
quintette à cordes de merak qu'ils
entament la dernière répétition un
programme cette année centrée sur mozart
vivaldi haydn de l'ambition qui a
nécessité une certaine exigence physique
pour des oeuvres classiques et baroque
met paradoxalement qui nécessite
énormément d'investissement physique du
corps a simplement des cordes vocales et
de chanter juste avec la hauteur des
notes mais vraiment de de se mettre en
route avec tout son corps de soutenir
d'avoir une énergie débordante et
parfois l'énergie on a du mal à la
trouver où aller la trouille au bon
endroit
parmi les choristes benoît mincir chefs
opérateurs sont dans la vie civile et
basse au sein de la croix-rouge plus
difficile c'est la mise en place comme
dit comme dit sandrine c'est de faire de
la musique tous ensemble c'est à dire
que de se détacher détacher son regard
de la partition et pouvoir
je veux dire communiquer avec le
avec le chef ce concert c'est le fruit
d'une saison de travail de préparation à
raison de deux heures par semaine et de
plusieurs dimanches dans l'année un
travail exigeant rendue possible par
l'ambiance qui règne au sein du groupe
et par la personnalité énergique de la
chef de choeur d'aucuns diraient que je
suis quelqu'un d'à peu près survoltée
voilà je pense surtout que faut avoir la
passion et l'amour de ce qu'on fait et
je crois énormément dans les capacités
et le potentiel du coeur que je fais
travailler je les pousse je les tire je
fais tout ce que je peux pour que voilà
à la fois ça sent bien et surtout qu'ils
se fassent plaisir se faire plaisir et
toujours progresser pour s'en rendre
compte il suffit d'assister à l'une des
répétitions janvier 2015 les choristes
découvre la partition au fur et à mesure
une séance démarre toujours de la même
manière
d'abord la mise en voix du corps
s'attacher à la respiration puis avant
le travail en commun la phase
d'apprentissage par pupitres les halles
qui les basses et les soprano se
regroupant niveau pour travailler leurs
morceaux nous retrouvons benoît le chef
opérateur sont il entama sa cinquième
saison au sein de la chorale dans son
enfance il a fait dix ans de piano et de
chant
j'aime la musique et puis j'aime aussi
là le spectacle et de mettre en danger
face un public et donner de soi même
maintenant on ne ralentit pas c'est pas
parce que ce sont juste de notes tenues
qu'il faut qu'il faut relâcher
voilà le relâcher la tension est bien
conservé cet état rythmique et pour lui
qui a l'oreille absolue pas question de
manquer une auto une respiration
il connaît les partitions parker l'outil
essentiel d'un choriste c'est son grand
papier ça donne
pour port pour tous repérés pour pour le
moindre petit détail de ce parce que un
ou deux choristes même si on est 50 ça
s'entend et voilà le public un peu
exercé en tant ses petits défauts qui
font toute la différence de la qualité
des décors direction les ailes ti avec
celle que l'on appelle la petite maman
du coeur odette gravier elle a intégré
la chorale il ya vingt ans dans le chant
choral ce qui me plaît m'a déjà que ce
sont des chants sacrés et moi j'ai
toujours été élevé dans une école
chrétienne
donc ça m'a plu et je trouve que
le fait de chanter on oublie tout six ou
si le niveau est assez haut c'était ça
mais avec sandrine bailly à elle nous
fait progresser à chaque fois
et m
l'instrument c'est notre corps en entier
de la racine des cheveux à la plante des
pieds et même quand on est fatigué
parfois le fait de chanter sa détente la
galvanisa donne de l'énergie
sandrine constituant la pierre angulaire
de cette chorale elle a fondé le coeur
il ya 20 ans à l'époque une dizaine de
personnes composaient le groupe
aujourd'hui ils sont une cinquantaine
les choristes seront 110 m de l'église
saint martin des clayes-sous-bois le 6
juin
avant d'entamer une autre série de
concerts dans la région oui c'est très
fiers d'eux-mêmes season leurs pas et
voilà je suis très fier de ce titre est
fier de vous c'est un concours national
de chant lancé l année dernière le vocal
tour fait escale à plaisir jusqu'à
samedi à la clé pour les gagnants
l'enregistrement d'un single ou des
cours de perfectionnement de chant
sephora namani et elodie moines marisa
candide est qualifié sur internet par le
public n'a jamais eu l'opportunité
d'envisager sa passion
professionnellement elle tente sa chance
pour la première fois sur scène
à quoi sont
c'est aussi un défi personnel parce
qu'on me le dit souvent mais fait de
voice mais fait quelque chose c'est pas
possible que tu continues dans ton petit
monde avec ton petit micro devant
l'ordinateur à la maison et c'est
peut-être mon opportunité de voir est ce
que je peux est-ce que je peux pas si je
gagne ça changera complètement ma vie
ça c'est sûr j'ai toujours eu ce rêve
pas beaucoup d'opportunités donc celle
là je la prends venu des yvelines et
d'île de france
les candidats ou vocale tour n'ont qu'un
objectif se faire repérer par les
professionnels du spectacle pour cela
face au public
les chanteurs ont quatre minutes pour
convaincre un jury composé notamment de
différents artistes et producteurs de
the voice en recherche de la
personnalité moi j'aime personnellement
j'aime j'aime les artistes qui ce qu'ils
se lâchent qu'ils ont de la personnalité
qui arrive à être à l'aise sur scène
après la technique vocale toutes ces
choses là ça c'est un autre type de
jugement parce que quand on a 15 ans ou
quand on a 40 ans on n'a pas travaillé
dans pareille de contact avec le public
il est très très très très très très
importante
omnium est extraordinaire bien situé
avec ma lumière est pour l'instant j'ai
entendu deux fois donc c'est très
agréable donc pourquoi pas des futures
stars lassaigne vocal tour après ses
quartiers dans la galerie commerciale
auchan du grand plaisir la compétition
se déroule jusqu'à samedi
l'enjeu est de taille pour ces artistes
amateurs puisque les trois lauréats
seront qualifiés pour la finale
nationale le 29 novembre prochain sur la
scène du trabendo
allez on continue cette édition un
invité nous a rejoints en plateau il est
yvelinois et auteur d'un livre original
est en pleine actualité
pierre-olivier guiffard bonjour bonjour
yolaine votre ouvrage à leur s'intitule
balles neuves carnet de route d'un bal
hausse de roland garros voilà il est ici
bas lorsqu'il est le surnom qu'on donne
aux ramasseurs de balle exactement alors
que raconte ce livre alors ce livre
raconte laventure de charlie charlie est
un des 250 ramasseurs de balle que l'on
croise dans les sur les terrains de
roland garros et qui nous raconte
comment il est devenu ramasseurs de
balles quelles ont été ses sélections et
que vite il au quotidien à roland garros
quels sont les coulisses de ce de cet
univers de roland garros d'un bal hausse
comment vous est venu à un livre alors
il y as en 2010 j'ai mal j'ai ma fille
mariam qui a passé les sélections pour
devenir ramasseuse de balle à jouer au
tennis au pecq
elle a passé les sélections elle a passé
trois semaines à roland garros quand
ramasseuse de balle et son petit frère
qui a deux ans de moins qu'elle s'est
dit tiens moi aussi j'ai envie de
découvrir cet univers il a passé les
sélections il a eu la chance d'être
d'être pris et il a évolué comme ça
comme sa soeur avec un petit plus au
niveau de l' aventure c'est qu'il a pu
accéder aux grands courts et accéder aux
grands courts la première année il a
participé à la finale il a voulu refaire
et il a eu la chance de pouvoir faire et
il en est là cette année à sa quatrième
aventure la dernière puisqu'il est
bientôt retraité et c'est comme ça que
je me suis dit tiens on voit les
ramasseurs de balle on connaît roland
garros mais ça pourrait être intéressant
de faire le mix des deux et comme j'aime
beaucoup écrire
j'en ai profité pour me mettre dans la
peau de ce ramasseurs de balles et de
les interviewer pour faire le livre sur
la cour il est sur le terrain oui on le
voit par le but c'est qu'on le voit pas
mais il est bien élevé il est bien
présent aux côtés des champions ils sont
coupés du monde extérieur les téléphones
sont sur le bureau du coach et ils
récupéreront ce soir à la fin du débrief
très bien à qui s'adresse ce livre s qui
s'adresse uniquement aux passionnés
tennis ou même aux non sportifs
il s'adresse aux non sportifs il va
s'adresser aux enfants qui se disent
tiens
comment on peut devenir ramasseurs de
balle c'est quoi leur vie comment ils
ont fait ce qu'ils connaissaient
quelqu'un donc saluer ça explique il ya
un côté pédagogique pour expliquer que
tout le monde peut tenter sa chance
et puis c'est également il s'adresse aux
parents aux adultes qui un jour se sont
peut-être poser la question aussi de
devoir les à côtés de deux des coulisses
de roland garros
votre livre vous l'avez rédigé avec la
collaboration du service ramasseurs de
balle de la fédération française de
tennis avait été entouré comment vous en
estrie pour écrire ce livre du coup vous
êtes basé sur les témoignages de vos
enfants alors je me suis basé sur les
témoignages de mes enfants je me suis
basé au but 6 sur les témoignages des
correspondants de mes enfants ce que
tous les ans en tant que parisien
on reçoit un provincial à la maison donc
on a vu un certain nombre de
correspondants et puis également les
coaches que j'ai interviewés en fait
toutes ces sites cet environnement que
j'ai pu côtoyer en leur demandant peu
lors leur histoire leur leurs envies
leurs motivations et puis beaucoup de
temps passé aussi avec david portier qui
est le responsable de ce service des
ramasseurs de balles à la fédération
française de tennis et arthur bongrand
qui est son adjoint
ça vient on l'a vu votre fissures sur
les images il faut préciser donc est sur
les bons course et pas toujours évident
d'arriver sur le chatrier sur le court
suzanne lenglen
c'est vraiment en fonction des
performances de chacun ils sont jugés
constamment quand même il ya une
évaluation quotidienne chaque fois que
vous voyez d une équipe de six
ramasseurs vous avez un coach qui est à
côté qui va les évaluer
qui va s'assurer que tout est en
conformité qui sont irréprochables et il
ya un système à près de deux montées
descentes en fonction de la performance
des des enfants ils peuvent évoluer sur
des grands courts coup tout comme s'ils
ont une journée un peu moins bonne
redescendre sur un cours intermédiaire
le
cette partie du jeu au cours de la
lecture de votre livre on découvre un
peu les étapes à franchir vous l'avez
dit des anecdotes aussi sur les petites
manies les superstitions des joueurs je
pense que vous vous entendre vous en
raconter de longues et que l'on voit
c'est un joueur français qui est richard
gasquet qui aiment bien qu'on le leur à
mes soeurs lui remette la serviette en
boule
généralement vous arrivez vous déployez
la serviette pour le joueur pour qu'il
n'est plus qu'à 6 juillet richard
gasquet est bien là la serviette en
boule et ça fait partie de son de son
rituel tout comme il aime bien récupérer
la dernière balle avec laquelle il a
gagné un point
donc le ramasseur doit suivre
l'évolution de la balle pour la
récupérer et la redonner à richard
gasquet d'accord c'est la superstition
on va dire que c'est leur routine ils
ont chacun une routine une façon de
faire qui rentrent dans leur dans leur
concentration dans votre livre si on
sent beaucoup l'ambiance et l'entr'aide
c'est très très importante entre ces
ramasseurs de balle qui passe trois
semaines ensemble c'est une bande de
copains s'est alors sont pas des
vacances parce que il ya une grosse
grosse activité physique mais en
revanche c'est une amitié qui se lie
entre eux avec lang l'encadrement il ya
beaucoup de bienveillance
physiquement c'est très difficile il
faut pas se leurrer ils ont une
préparation physique haddock mais
derrière l'esprit d'équipé c'est la
vraie valeur que qui leur est enseignée
ensemble a précisé qu'il ya deux
sélections va pas tout dire tout est
dans votre livre
il ya deux sélections quand même
importante il son début combien 3 milles
plus de 3000 pratiquement 4000 cette
année et finalement 220 sont
sélectionnés à chaque fois pour pour les
trois semaines où les quinze jours ce
sont 220 nouveaux et puis 30 anciens qui
ont la chance sur motivation de revenir
partager cette aventure alors avec votre
expérience de père de deux enfants qui
sont passés par là quels conseils
donneriez justement à ces enfants qui
rêve de devenir un jour ramasseurs de
balle de se faire plaisir de tenter les
sélections l'avantagent quand vous
passez les sélections vous allez de prix
tant mieux vous n'êtes pas pris vous
avez quand même le t-shirt ramasseurs
roland garros et vous passez une journée
qui est en termes de en termes de des
veilles d'éducation de plaisir qui est
super si vous êtes dans le mille
environnement
du tennis donc vous aimer le tennis vous
êtes jeune vous avez entre 12 et 16 ans
allez-y 4 au 24 ont finalement votre
fils maintenant fais partie des anciens
il va prendre sa retraite comme on le
dit exactement des ramasseurs il
souhaite poursuivre l'aventuré devenir
coach exactement devenir coach c'est
pour lui la possibilité finalement de
faire de l'encadrement des équipes
il est un senior dans le moule dizier
dans l'est dans les ramasseurs après
pouvoir accompagner d'autres ramasseurs
partager leurs aventures
il sera plus sur le terrain il sera dans
les coulisses mais il pourra là derrière
développer de nouvelles de compétences
dans un environnement qu'il adore
l'environnement du sport pour un enfant
tout comme pour sa soeur c'est quelque
chose d'exceptionnel
vous aviez vous avez été vous ramasseurs
de balle et en amour j'étais ramasseur
de balle des internationaux de royan
d'accord 1982 d'accord j'étais tout
petit et c'était un tournoi atp à
l'époque mais ça n'avait rien à voir
avec roland garros j'imagine roland
garros est quand même le grand chelem
donc votre livre je le rappelle il est
ici balles neuves carnet de route à un
ballot de roland garros c'est son nom on
peut le trouver ou pour les yvelines
alors vous pouvez le commander dans
toutes les librairies en donnant le en
donnant le nom et vous pouvez le trouver
en ligne sur des sites comme comme
amazon son coût n'a pas évoqué il est il
est de 15 euros aux livres très bien un
pronostic peut-être pour ce roland
garros
le pronostic du coeur ce serait un
français et au hasard je dirais c'est
tsonga après la raison voudrait que ce
soit djoko parce qu'il est réellement
impressionnant cette année bon on croise
les bras les doigts pour ce mondial
qu'on est en train de jouer sa
demi-finale un grand merci d'être venu
sur notre plateau et bonne fin de
tournoi vous merci beaucoup
on continue cette édition compte à nous
avec l actualité cinéma du week end et
tout de suite les sorties ciné de la
semaine et les avis des spectateurs au
micro d' elodie moins très émouvant ça
raconte une belle histoire entre
c'est entre ses amis qui découvre sa
maladie et qui le soutiennent jusqu'au
bout de ses projets il ya tout en fait
on rigole pas mal et en même temps c'est
un petit peu très émouvant et mais c'est
quand même un bon film de bons acteurs
aussi très très bien c'est un très bon
film
après je suis venu le voir c'est pas
trop de l'histoire mais c'est assez
assez sympa une jolie histoire d'amour
j'ai bien aimé matthieussent connacht
très séduisant très beau chine winter
berg connaissez c'est un metteur en
scène danois et je trouve que c'est une
très très bonne adaptation du roman je
trouve que c'est un bon film c'est
intéressant c'est sur les nouvelles
technologies et donc je trouve que le
thème il est assez intéressant
voici un film de science fiction sur les
robots mais bon peut-être qu'un jour les
robots ils font pareil se vengeront de
l'être humain
ouais c'est pas mal c'est vraiment bien
elle est du sport pour terminer avec une
autre journaliste sportif michael elle
me d'euros qui nous a rejoint en plateau
bonjour alors la saison la saison
sportive touche à sa fin je sais que
vous êtes très triste et yolaine vous
connaissez ma passion pour le sport
exactement
il n'y a plus dans le bal de rugby ou
bien de basket ball mais rassurez vous
il y aura du football ce week-end avec
les championnats départementaux et
régionaux
il y aura du suspense croyez moi j'ai
sélectionné pour vous deux rencontres
phares en promotion d'honneur trappe se
déplace sur le terrain de pontoise im ce
dimanche à 15h30 pour cette 22e et
ultime journée de ce championnat
quatrième du classement avec 51 points
les trappistes ont pu rien à espérer
dans ce championnat
une victoire leur permettrait de
terminer une très belle quatrième place
un résultat encore inespéré fin février
quand l'équipe flirter avec la zone de
relégation
cette victoire permettra également à
l'équipe de se jauger en vue de la
saison prochaine
toujours en football mais cette fois ci
en deuxième division de district magny
les hameaux troisième du classement
reçoit bailly noisy 8e du championnat
pour un derby sulfureux ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade jacques anquetil cette
rencontre vaut de l'or pour les manies
quoi l'équipe dirigée par farid gagny
doit l'emporter sur un score fleuve pour
espérer monter l'année prochaine et
saint quentinois doivent aussi espérer
une défaite des clayes-sous-bois et du
chéné l'équipe de magny les hameaux
va-t-elle montée réponse ce dimanche à
17h il y aura également du baseball avec
le coup gare de montigny le bretonneux
bretonneux les montants doivent
obligatoirement be with you l'aisne
les cougars de mon team auto se déplace
sur le terrain dessine donc c'est en
gironde ce dimanche cette 8e journée du
championnat de deuxième division est
très importante pour les il monte un
avant dernier du classement les joueurs
d'alexandre couteau affiche pour
l'instant un bilan de six défaites et de
cinq victoires
conséquence les cougars doivent
impérativement rugir de nouveau pour se
qualifier pour les play-offs de fin de
saison les victoires contre
et si les relancerait totalement dans ce
championnat ce ne sera pas simple le
dernier match entre les deux équipes
s'est soldé par une victoire pour
montigny et une victoire et une défaite
contre sin est alors enfin un dernier
rendez vous à noter dans vos agendas il
aura du tir à l'arc et solitaire
effectivement violaine il y aura du tir
à l'arc la compagnie d'arc d'elancourt
organise ce week-end la dernière étape
de la division régionale en équipe
la compétition est programmée samedi et
dimanche de 9h30 à 17h et 400 meilleurs
archers franciliens seront présents pour
ce grand rendez vous dans le détail les
épreuves individuelles
duels sont programmées le matin elles
permettront de classer les différentes
équipes présentes en additionnant les
scores de la matinée les matches en
équipe seront programmées l'après midi
les trois premiers de la division
excellence rond taxe à la finale
nationale de division régionale pour
monter en deuxième division
voilà yolaine vous connaissez tous les
résultats tous les pros le programme ce
week-end moi personnellement je vais
aller voir le match entre magny les
hameaux et bailly noisy vous me tuer je
vous accompagne en vous connaissez ma
passion pour le football
évidemment au rendez vous donc dimanche
à 15 heures merci beaucoup michael c'est
la fin de cette édition quant à nous je
vous souhaite un excellent week end sur
tf1